do you prefer making plans for a project
or do you prefer to have plans made for
you and then carry them out I like
making my own plans ironically the film
that I just directed hipsters gangsters
aliens and geeks is only really the
second time since Forbidden Zone that
I've directed my own material
now other stuff I've been a hired gun
and it's exhilarating and this is where
I like to be I plan my dinners I plan my
films okay dad so down to the course
yeah yeah yeah it's a you know
particular when I'm cooking for a lot of
people I go through every step of what
I'm gonna do beforehand just like a shot
list for a film mentally you know
because you've got to be organized with
all this stuff happening and then
something like a spice is missing or the
fires too hot or celiac shows up yeah
you don't know that yeah yeah what do
you do how do you improvise you just
roll with the punches but I'll cook for
up to 200 people you know with helpers
okay with helpers okay so do you almost
see dinner as its own theatre in some
sense the theatrics of getting
everything ready and chopping it up yeah
yeah I again I'm an entertainer and also
one of the things I said I've been a
Food & Wine columnist forever and I look
at us as spiritual beings in a physical
body and the way the physical body
experiences the universe is through our
five senses and just like art for the
eyes music for the ears the palate is
also one of the ways that we as
spiritual beings experience the universe
and that's something that I really I
lived in France for three years and
that's something that I really took in
was the art for the palate with food and
wine that's interesting how do you see
the French experience with film versus
the American experience
hahaha well I was in a theater company
and
[Laughter]
we had a hit show and we were in one
film and the French would drink wine
during lunch and it would be hours
before they get the next shot off and
then there's like we have our kind of
three acts story structure you know in
its sighting incident da da da da de in
the finale okay the French story
structure is they don't take off their
clothes and screw till the second act
[Laughter]
okay there's an arc no no but I
appreciate the I love France by one of
my son's is half French oh okay yeah
yeah no I mean they're they're amazing
they're amazing and everything that they
do the French yeah yeah but I know that
they have very you know specific
approaches to things and I just wondered
do you think that Americans are super
controlled in their approach to the
artistic process or that's just a
fallacy
III don't people are different in every
culture and you'll find you know
left-brain right-brain you'll find
everything in every culture sure would
you say you're right right
pretty much so although I kept one foot
in business at the same time so I've got
a little bit of a left brain the right
brain gets it into trouble a little
Steve Jobs is someone that I idolized
and he had seen like both in many ways
and so do you see that as being a
blessing or is it in some ways difficult
to come heart mentalize the right versus
the left because one will fight with the
other well one okay so look at like like
one wants money for the project and the
other wants to pay the bills you know so
we do have you know that uh I think of
that Seinfeld episode where the mr.
penis and mr. brain are arguing with
each other over who gets to do what I
wasn't expecting that reference and I
have one more answer that I thought of
earlier for the kiosk me the one about
that dealing with adversity and stuff
like that oh please go ahead okay so I
put on big parties and big events
so I've got something I'm co-hosting it
with a major Hollywood producer we've
got all these bigwigs black-tie so I'm a
afro-latin percussionist I play in a
Brazilian bateria so I had an
afro-brazilian group the sweetest people
you'd ever meet voice and percussion and
people are all drunk and inna like that
the music's going and I've got the head
of a studio with his bimbo so as they
passed my musicians he made some
denigrating remark boy why couldn't they
get some real music and it cut these
guys it was the biggest night of the
year for them and so I don't know if it
was the two bottles of champagne or the
full moon but I picked the little
up and threw him in the swimming pool
there you go like Dracula like you're
never gonna work again I've got
tuberculosis you know he went in the
pool he didn't like it
and everyone secretly like go I go
loving it and then his bimbo went off
like a banshee I threw her in and I went
back to my Brazilians and apologized for
his boorish behavior oh wow whose water
borscht borscht oh I say okay I was
gonna say either and as he said I did
work for a few years in Hollywood I mean
is it so controlled that really if you
don't acquiesce to someone and not even
have a confrontation at that level but
let's suppose there's a slight someone
feels slighted could that really ruin
someone's career I'm not sure it's a I
mean also what happened is I've always
kept one foot in like real estate
investment in development and when I
threw him in I was worth so many million
and then the market crashed and I wasn't
worth that much a year later so that
affected things it might have affected
by decision if I do the market was going
to crash to thousands of campaign
notwithstanding I see okay you think
money gives people confidence it helps
you know you can hire a lawyer and get
out of trouble but not just that not
just the the legal aspect but in terms
of how you approach things if you feel
that
by me having color like the left brain
side and having at least some real
estate income coming in every month if I
modest I don't have to work and I can
just choose projects that I like so I'm
not forced to take jobs that I hate sure
yes yeah sure that helps you know I've
got a family
sure yeah I just you know there's the a
lot of debate about that but I would
imagine that having knowing that you
could not have to do something that you
don't want to do for a year and be okay
probably lends confidence to how you
approach things and then that yeah yeah
yeah yeah it does it does I I watched my
father God he he'd often have two three
jobs he eventually became a
schoolteacher he's supporting two
families one from before the war went
from after the war he'd get up before
dawn and deliver milk then have tutoring
things in the evenings and on weekends
had factory jobs I've had to do a bit of
that but not to the degree that my
father had to that's interesting yeah I
was listening to the author John Updike
speaking he saw his father struggle as
well and he was a teacher and it just
he knew that he didn't want to be a
company man and I'm not not to use that
in a derogatory term but in terms of
being sort of owned by somebody and
knowing that that ownership can tell you
okay now it's time to go and all the
problems that that causes so did you
know that you never wanted to sort of
work a corporate job because of that
same side of same sort of I just I've
been blessed enough that I really
haven't had to I've done I've been a cab
driver I've been a busboy I've tended
bar but those things were shorter term
and involuntary I was doing artistic
stuff and and right now I don't have to
do stuff like that you tend bar for
yourself for friends and family past and
crew but that's my pleasure that's
that's my greatest enjoyment yeah is to
cook and feed people and to entertain
them we
do theatrical dinners yeah